[Musik]
ja wir sind jetzt hier noch in kasan in
russland wären die deutsche mannschaft
sich gerade auf dem weg in richtung
heimat nach deutschland befindet auf dem
rückflug und sie haben eine ganz schöne
last mit im gepäck einen die frage wie
geht es mit dem bundestrainer weiter
nach einer historischen niederlage dem
ersten ausscheiden in der vorrunde und
es ist auch so was wie ein mythos auch
gestern abend zerbrochen nämlich was
generell in den necker gesagt hat dass
fußball ist ein einfaches spiel mit 22
männern wie ball hinterherlaufen und am
ende gewinnt eben nicht immer
deutschland
da es jetzt eine ganze menge zu ende
gegangen und es wird eine ganze menge
arbeit bedürfen um das wieder aufzubauen
was ihm bei dieser weltmeisterschaft
verloren gegangen
die mannschaft hat sich nie wirklich
gefunden es war keine mannschaft die
vergleichbar gewesen wäre mit dem team
von 2014 keine mannschaft gewesen die
vergleichbar gewesen wäre mit dem jungen
team des confed-cups von 2017 die
mischung hat nicht gestimmt es gab zum
teil eben spieler die nicht mehr ihre
form gefunden haben weltmeister jens
zenit schon überschritten haben junge
spieler die nicht in dem maße in die
mannschaft gekommen sind wie es
notwendig gewesen wäre um sie zu
verjüngen und zu erfrischen ihnen
geschwindigkeit zu verleihen das ist
etwas was dieser mannschaft absolut
gefehlt hat tempo geschwindigkeit und
damit verbundene spielstärke die sie
ihren besten zeiten ausgezeichnet hat
aber das hat sich schon seit wochen und
monaten vermissen lassen
aber die zeichen die wir hier auch oft
angesprochen haben die wurden nie so
ernst genommen
es hieß immer na ja wenn das turnier
dann losgeht dann ist der weltmeister
auf den punkt da aber das hat sich
tatsächlich nicht bewahrheitet
jetzt stehen die mannschaft eben da wo
sie steht tabellenletzter der gruppe auf
dem heimflug und ein neuanfang muskeln
aktiviert
[Musik]
die weltmeister die tüte hat dem der
mannschaft und dem trainer den letzten
vier jahren definitiv nicht gut getan
100 man eben nicht dadurch dass man sich
satt gegessen hat sondern bekommt man
dadurch wenn man eben hunger hat wenn
man wenn man etwas erreichen will und
die darum hat jetzt wollen sie jetzt
auch wieder gepäck zeit und am besten
eben mit neun spielern und auch mit dem
neuen trainer
[Musik]